jamais tu un petit peu particulier un
métier qui n'existait pas il ya quelques
années je suis auteur comédien
réalisateur monteur producteur de vidéos
sur internet youtube heures passées ça
dans quelques années je pense que tout
le monde sera ce que c'est on va arrêter
de poser des questions c'est très bien
ce que c'est un youtube heures mais pour
l'instant c'est le gros bordel mon
métier vu par ma grand et jambon beurre
c'est un métier à part mon voisin chez
le voisin il parle encore tout seul
j'appelle l ambulance la police
j'appelle la police une marque peut
tenir ce panneau dans sa prochaine vidéo
1 histoire de cinq minutes on n'est pas
non plus par un et terrestres de la
merde je préfère pierre desproges c'est
un autre tu me paraît un enfant lutins
je vais le tibet heures par semaine on
youtube heures c'est pas un métier un
jour naître argent argent argent et j'ai
terminé mon article dans la mère de
l'enfant
oui mon fils tu vas faire youtube et ça
je vais faire payer des cours pour être
youtuber diop ap ap ap ap attendait et
ce que je viens de découvrir une école
pour être star du net tard d'une est un
vrai métier rassure ta mère mais c'est
ma mère en dehors de ça s'il vous plaît
ça parle pas de devenir vidéaste ou
hauteur mais bien star star comme
jeremstar et que proposent les
formations qui vont jusqu'à 1500 euros
l'optimisation la monétisation les
partenariats
waouh ça annonce des vidéos de qualité
tout ce qu'on adore sur youtube heures
finalement eu tueur team is et monétiser
partenariés bon si vous voulez pas
dépenser mille cinq cents euros je
vous donner un cours gratuit pour
réussir à coup sûr sur internet le cours
de professeurs cyprien bonjour ça a créé
un petit peu l'on prenait des notes je
pars répétaient fait des bonnes vidéos
régulièrement
moi j'en ai c'était le cours de
professeurs cyprien star de youtube ça
mais les assurés voilà c'est cadeau ça
me fait plaisir de regarder votre argent
en or ces petits noms en école qui
peuvent vous servir sur youtube via les
écoles de du visuel voilà pour rendre le
montage du cadrage de la lumière le son
ça peut toujours servir depuis que je
fais des vidéos sur internet j'analyse
tout ce que je vois et je prends des
notes sur mon téléphone
voilà ce qui me fait marrer comme ça ça
me servira pour une prochaine vidéo un
court métrage une bd comme une idée ça
peut arriver à n'importe quel moment bas
ça va faire un peu bizarre pour mon
entourage
cyprien je te dise quelque chose j'ai vu
mon médecin m
annoncé que j'avais une grave maladie
incurable que je risque de mourir dans
les po à d'accord du tout en bas les
couilles de cela quand on voit comment
t'écrire catapulte co2 n ard catapulte
bon par contre mes notes c'est écrit
n'importe comment et 90% servira jamais
rien et fille sur instagram
elles ont des démangeaisons elle se
gratte la tête tout le temps à satee
manche ignoble photo je dois avoir des
landes
ben je sais pas pourquoi j'ai noté ça
mais cela à quoi ressemble mais journée
de youtube heures tous les matins je lis
mes mails c'est un petit peu mon petit
rituel malheureusement je peux pas
répondre à tout le monde et tous les
matins j'ai des petites pépites bonjour
cyprien tu peux venir à mon anniversaire
samedi prochain malheureusement j'ai un
truc samedi je suis deg cela un bon
anniversaire de quelqu'un que je connais
pas c'est ce que je préfère bonjour
cyprien tu peux parler de ma chaîne
youtube
je veux faire le buzz en tout cas il ya
une bonne école pour thoiras sur ta mère
il ya une bonne école pour faire un
métier
bonjour norman jolie sont tout un petit
peu différente mais ya des choses qui
prennent plus ou moins de temps le plus
important c'est l'écriture as beaucoup
de temps à écrire en ce moment j'écris
des vidéos pour youtube
deux courts métrages une série roger
c'est humain tome 2 et 2 jeux vidéo et
tout ce que j'écris tout seul d'autre
que j'écris à plusieurs surtout je suis
spécialiste de la désorganisation du
coup j'ai écrit tout en même temps pas
très rapidement comme ça ça n'avance pas
vite si vous voulez des consignes et
d'écriture pour avancer ensuite nous
avons les tournages ça prend quelques
jours et le montage aussi des vidéos
quelques jours aussi
et il est vrai de temps en temps je
m'autorise à jouer à des jeux vidéo je
m'excuse je m'excuse je suis désolé a
depuis que sur youtube heures j'ai
croisé plein de gens qui m'ont sorti une
phrase un peu bizarre vous voyez la
fuite est juste là et mieux vous n'êtes
pas de mec de youtube compagnie dont
selon moi c'est marrant comme
avertissement comme si je faisais des
vidéos sur toutes les personnes que je
croise cinq minutes charest aujourd'hui
j'ai vu le mec de youtube
chaque année des vies sont brisées par
les youtuber youtube ça évolue
énormément moi j'ai créé ma chaîne en
2007 me rappelle encore des débuts sur
la vidéo et a posté hier 200 vu
aujourd'hui c'est plus pareil
je suis dégoûté de le sentiment vidéo
nierle a fui 100 milliards est sur moi
tu as fait la recette de base bien sûr
sur la miniature j'ai fait une grimace
un contour blanc une fille au trône
jusqu'à l'interaction avec les
internautes
je fais et ça continue comme ça tu vas
devoir sinon si tu vas devoir avoir de
l'imagination
il ya un aspect nord le fait d'être
youtuber avec lequel je suis moins à
l'aise c'est le fait d'être une
personnalité publique tout ce que je dis
va être analysée décortiquée sorti du
contexte
je peux dire par exemple sur twitter
j'aime bien jurassic park placement de
produit pour jurassic park assesseurs et
préfère parler des blockbusters plutôt
que documentaire sur les bombardements
en syrie cyprien il s'en fout de ce qui
se passe à l'étranger saint cyprien
n'aime pas les étrangers je vais le dire
sur twitter cyprien raciste 9000 roux
tweets
vous êtes raciste vous répondez quoi la
polémique
bien jurassic park on doit
[Musique]